i watch them fight
in the name of freedom they speak of
liberty and justice but for who
video games have become one of our most
impactful popular and creative forms of
media
last year the industry generated almost
a hundred and fifty billion dollars in
revenue worldwide rivaling books and
films and wharfing music gamers spend
over three billion hours a week in the
virtual worlds of their choosing and
more so than any other contemporary form
of media video games explore the themes
of freedom and personal agency allowing
players to go where they want and to do
what they please as long as they're
prepared to bear the consequences
two of the three best-selling video
games of all time are Grand Theft Auto 5
and minecraft polar opposites in terms
of violence and target audience that
both of which we're designed to offer
players the opportunity to make their
own destinies and unstructured
activities for you to do but there's one
franchise that stands apart in its focus
on individualism Liberty and personal
responsibility both in its style of
gameplay and the stories it tells it's
called Assassin's Creed the series is
set in an alternate history where
assassins who value freedom wage a
secret war against Templars who believe
in totalitarian control both sides
insist that their ultimate goal is peace
but differ on how to achieve it
I followed my oneth believing in my
Catholic
hey Matthew the assassins are the good
guys of the games and their outlook is
also the most libertarian as outlined by
their Creed to recognize nothing is true
and everything is permitted that laws
arise not from divinity but reason I
understand now that our Creed does not
command us to be free it commands us to
be wise and one of the franchise's
earliest and overall best protagonists
can't elaborate further
you mentioned the Creed before what is
it nothing is true everything is
permitted that is rather cynical it
would be if it were doctrine but it is
merely an observation of the nature of
reality to say that nothing is true is
to realize that the foundations of
society are fragile and that we must be
the Shepherd's of our own civilization
to say that everything is permitted is
to understand that we are the architects
of our actions we must live with our
consequences whether glorious or tragic
put another way individuals are
ultimately responsible for what they
believe what they do and the
consequences of both which isn't to say
that these games are simplistic
anti-authoritarian agitprop the
antagonists aren't just cartoonishly
evil villains bent on power for powers
sake the series portrays the Templars as
human beings who for the most part
sincerely want to make the world better
succeeded hey let me play my part part
of the puppeteer no the string should be
severed
should be free
who wish to live forever from castles in
the sky you will tear a blade like a man
but your life like a child her more will
die man because of her
and the assassins are themselves flawed
corruptible and suffered from internal
contradictions
for example they claim to believe in
freedom while at the same time relying
on violence and putting absolute faith
in their rules and traditions Assassin's
Creed teaches us that our ideological
adversaries aren't evil usually they
share our values often they have a very
different concept of how to obtain the
same goals it also drives home the
lesson that however much human beings
think they've got life figured out
nobody has perfect knowledge Assassin's
Creed is more than a series of games
about sneaking up on people and stabbing
it's a franchise about the nuances and
tragedy of human struggles the
complexity of opposing ideologies and
how the lines between them blur in
beneath it all how the choice between
good and evil is deeply personal and
ultimately rests with the individual
alone
[Music]